hey Rick that season six Premiere was
really good but like thematically what
was it all about and and where does the
show go from here no time to explain
here we go
so there was time to explain who has
ever taken this long to vanish I'm
gonna start the episode now okay stop
digging digging for hidden layers and
there's
impressed
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that knows that what people
call curiosity is just a chemical that
compels animals to seek out knowledge
ladies and gromplamites Rick Sanchez and
the rest of his dysfunctional family are
back and they came back hard last week
season six Premiere Solaris did not
disappoint I know there's been a lot of
discussion lately about Rick and Morty
losing its way over the last season or
so but if this new episode is anything
to judge by it looks like the show is
coming back swinging huge lore reveals
check my original Rick killed your
family seems like you understand fine
Morty that was a plus re-piping
Hilarious Moments double check hey
remember like a second ago when you
pretended not to know who Iron Man was
who was that for the introduction of a
brand new villain check again oh you
found me I shoot the first monitor too
but there's also something else that's
hiding under the surface of this episode
something new something that makes me
hopeful for the future of the series
healing well there's certainly a lot of
plot going on in this episode something
that a lot of other channels have talked
about exhaustively in Recaps and
explainers by this point I see a whole
lot less discussion on the themes of
this particular episode I mean plot wise
the show did more than enough to bring
everyone up to speed with what they
needed to know I explained it fine Morty
your spoon feeding spoons but
thematically this episode is a pivotal
moment for the franchise as the
characters pull not just a full
dimensional reset but also a full
emotional reset so consider this lesson
analysis of what happened in the episode
and more a breakdown of what I think
this episode is actually trying to say
to the audience what themes are Rick and
Morty gonna be exploring throughout
season six because between all the
Sci-Fi mind games and portal gunless
Dimension hopping this show is doing
something else it's showing us two
different and seemingly opposite
strategies for coping with grief I know
I know animated therapy is everyone's
favorite subject to talk about when it
comes to their favorite wacky sci-fi
comedy cartoon but what Rick and Morty
the show and this episode in particular
have shown us is that traumatic
experiences like watching your wife and
daughter murdered right in front of you
those are things that are gonna come
with consequences not just consequences
for the Lord lore of the franchise but
also emotional consequences consequences
that affect what these characters are
and what they want to be moving forward
so reset your Portal guns and your
expectations loyal theorists because
we're going in case you missed the
episode here's what you need to know the
episode picks up exactly where season
five left off Rick and Morty stranded on
the destroyed remains of The Citadel in
Portal technology completely
non-operable they're eventually saved by
Captain Marvel I mean space Beth Rick
accidentally resets all portal Travelers
back to their original Dimensions which
sends Jerry back to a failing season 2
marriage with Beth Morty back to the
Cronenberg monster universe from when
his Jessica Love Potion when awry and
Rick back to the garage where he lost
his wife and daughter this one moment
finally confirms once and for all Rick's
backstory that he was indeed blue pants
Rick he was built differently he wasn't
interested in being the smartest guy in
the universe excuse me bro rich don't
pass on this it also makes me wonder if
evil Morty was also reset to his
original Dimension by this move but that
remains to be seen anyway we see the
prison of grief that Rick has created
for himself the voice of his dead wife
Diane always one room away in a day
that's set to repeat infinitely
meanwhile Morty meets up with his
original Jerry who is not happy to see
him summer and Beth have both died and
so Jerry has moved on with his life he's
a Survivor he'll do anything to help his
chances this includes stealing Morty
stuff rejecting his help and leaving him
to die throughout this fastest had to
set trap thought you'd have coolers
meanwhile summer Beth and space Beth go
on a mini adventure to set portal
navigation beacons for Rick to follow
back to their Universe hashing out their
own issues of family and identity while
fighting alien space squids with
interdimensional travel now made easier
Rick hops on over to the Cronenberg
Universe to save Morty and then seeks
out the Rick from Morty's Dimension the
same sci-fi Rick Prime that killed his
wife and daughter setting the entire
series into motion tracking Rick Prime
to his invisible space base our Rick
goes on a suicidal Rampage in an attempt
to kill him but he stopped when Morty
convinces Rick that his new family is
more important than getting revenge Rick
and Mort already pick up Summer Beth and
space Beth before saving Jerry from the
unhappy marriage in his original
Universe heading home together as a
happy family unit until season 2 Jerry
releases a cute Abomination that ruins
everything
way to go Jerry cue the family having to
find another new dimension though here
they're gonna have to deal with one
annoying trait bit of a rush job
actually so they do say parmesan weird
how do they say parmesan so I'm guessing
that everyone picked up on the biggest
running theme throughout this episode
Rick's grief over his dead family the
whole haunted by the digital ghost of
your dead wife thing isn't exactly
subtle as Rick returns to his original
Dimension we as the audience see that
his past strategies for coping with the
loss of his wife and daughter have been
well as unhealthy and over the top as
you would expect from a man like Rick
Sanchez unable to fully accept the loss
of his wife Diane Rick recreated her as
an AI a literal disembodied voice that
follows him throughout their home always
just out of sight and one room away you
thought if you could see or touch me it
might give you level of comfort but of
course because this is a creation made
by Rick meant to torture himself the AI
is also eager to bring up the young Beth
who tragically never made it past
childhood did you find out
you'll find him you always do everything
you set your mind to accept keep your
family alive well all of this might seem
cruel remember it's self-inflicted
cruelty Rick created this Ai and
everything that it does is ultimately
something that he programmed into it
you're not her you're a thing I built to
torture myself in this Dimension Rick is
living in a mental prison of his own
creation and he isn't the only one in
his grief he's also forcing everyone
around him to live in a physical prison
as well Rick is so unwilling to let go
of the past that he's kept his home in a
state of Perpetual stasis pulling a wand
division by locking his real-life
neighbors into a cycle that repeats the
same day over and over and over for the
decades that Rick's been gone his trauma
has trapped the innocent bystanders in a
never-ending Loop all because he's
unable to let go of the past they say my
mind is held captive in a Time Loop
trapped in the day of a traumatic event
by the agony of a formidable
intelligence that my body spoils and
yearns for death so in Rick The Show
presents us with a man who clearly
cannot let go the trauma of his past
he's created a prison for himself he
submerges himself in suffering every day
clearly this is not the healthiest
strategy for confronting your grief
something that the show repeatedly
hammers home or weirdo I pity them wish
they could let go and move on sounds
healthy sure would be but while that's
already a powerful commentary on the
power of grief and what it can do if it
consumes you this episode also shows a
completely different way for a father to
react to the death of his wife and
daughter and no we're no longer talking
about Rick here see Rick isn't the only
man who's lost his family in this
episode as Morty returns to his home
Dimension now a jungle covered
Cronenberg post-apocalyptic Wasteland we
meet his original Jerry life on the
hellscape has not been easy sadly it was
more than this universe's Beth and
summer could survive we've spent a long
time in that ice a gentle mutant licked
us out but Beth got sick and summer
didn't thought by the time our Morty
finds him this Jerry stands alone
against the world a hardened Survivor
but unlike Rick who's been stuck in the
past Jerry's a man who's chosen to let
go to move forward to get over the loss
of his loved ones your mom and sister
died Morty and I moved on from caring
and that is the best deal you will ever
get so take it Jerry's worked so hard to
get over this pain that he wants nothing
to do with his own son with a long lost
Morty finally returns to the home
Dimension so the show is very clearly
presenting us with two different fathers
both confronted with the horrible
reality of a dead partner and child
reacting to it in two seemingly opposite
ways one Rick is stuck in the past while
the other Jerry is looking towards the
future Rick is desperately clinging to
what he's lost while Jerry would just as
soon forget it all entirely giving up
everything else he had in his old life
in the process now whenever Rick and
Morty shows us this kind of black and
white contrast It's usually the
Creator's way of trying to tell us
something it's almost as if the Rick and
Morty writers are pitting these two
opposite coping strategies against each
other to see which one works but instead
of choosing sides here Solaris is
actually telling us that these methods
aren't all that different though it
seems like both Rick and Jerry are
dealing with grief in opposite ways the
truth is that they're making the same
mistake as much as Jerry might talk
about leaving the past behind looking
forward and moving on with his life he's
still haunted by his past just as much
as Rick is we see this at the end of the
episode when Rick Prime shows up in the
Cronenberg Dimension Jerry sees this as
an opportunity to take revenge on the
people who ruined the world that he knew
do you hate them too I could be done for
a little teamwork now admittedly that
might have just been a fake out in
Jerry's part to fool Rick Prime into
letting his guard down but throughout
the rest of the episode we repeatedly
see that while Jerry says that he's let
go he clearly hasn't when Morty shows up
Jerry is only willing to talk to him on
friendly terms for as long as it takes
to steal all his stuff Jerry is actively
running away from serious conversations
with his natural born son leaving notes
behind as a distraction technique in
order to buy him time in order to escape
even if they weren't related this might
be the only other normal unmutated human
left on the planet but Jerry can't seem
to accept any kind of future that
involves accepting Morty's help even
ones that get him away from this live
living nightmare if Rick comes back we
can we can find you a new reality a new
mom a new summer a job oh you don't get
a cam except for this conversation my
life is perfect Rick was always right
everyone needs to let go he's taken
Rick's advice of Letting Go and
stretched it to its unhealthiest extreme
he's let go of being a dad to Morty and
summer a husband to Beth part of society
as a whole all of that is part of the
man that Jerry used to be on a surface
level that might seem like he's escaped
from his past but the truth is that he's
just blindly running from his past and
blindly running from your past is still
letting that grief control you our Rick
and this original Jerry are both men who
never really process the grief of losing
their families Rick chose to wallow in
his grief while Jerry chose to run away
from it these look like different
responses but ultimately both approaches
have the same Consequence the grief
remains unresolved it continues to haunt
them in Rick's case it's a literal
haunting an AI ghost and a nightmare
reality of his own creation and while
Jerry might not have been directly
responsible for creating this particular
nightmare world he he refuses to leave
it when the opportunity presents itself
he chooses to remain there just like
Rick I mean this right here is not the
face of a man who's happy or satisfied
with his course of life you see the show
is presenting us with a false dichotomy
here where the only choices seem to be
clinging to the past and drowning in
your grief or running from the past and
ignoring your grief but as it so often
happens the real solution is to reject
the false dichotomy and choose a third
option confronting the grief and
resolving it and that's what Rick and
Morty both the show and the characters
are trying to tell us in this episode
this is how you resolve Rick's character
Arc so what does a healthy approach to
dealing with grief look like well
according to Dr J William Warden of
Harvard Medical School a mental health
expert who specializes in grief
counseling the solution to negative
feelings isn't to numb them like Rick so
often does nor is it to run from them
like we see with Jerry here no the
solution is to accept those emotions to
feel them so your body and brain can
move forward with the best parts of your
life while leaving behind the painful
remnants now that's not to say that you
should seek out your green even inflict
emotional pain on yourself I mean we've
been watching Rick do that to himself
for the entirety of the show seeking out
pain because that's what he thinks he
deserves but accepting pain is not the
same as seeking it out and Rick seems to
be moving past that phase of his
grieving in fact Rick seems to be
embracing one of Dr Warren's recommended
methods for healthy grief processing
learning to rely on family you know I
guess it doesn't matter where we're from
if we're together huh good final moral
thing this is everyone's original
Dimension now great wrap ups kids for
all his attempts to push them away in
the end Rick realizes the importance of
family even if the family he has now is
a found family assembled from variants
and clones that he's gathered from
throughout the Multiverse and when Mr
frontals escapes containment and puts
everyone at risk see what happens though
Rick is quick to bail on the entire
Dimension notice the one thing he
doesn't bail on is his family he could
have left you guys you think the concept
of Family Matters to me I'm not even
your Rick that's right Rick you could
have left them behind but you didn't
because unlike Rick Prime you care I
promise I'm not you know fate to make
that Rick comeback for you to be bait
the guide have to Value something in
fact I think we see the very moment
where the switch flips in Rick's mind
when Morty doesn't let Rick continue on
his mission to kill Rick Prime go down
there he's
still good what good care of you die why
do you care if I die yeah when you get
it from him not me I don't know him
you're my grandpa Rick Rick and Morty a
hundred years in that moment Rick
realizes that protecting Morty his
living family is more important than
avenging his dead family though Rick
doesn't quite give up on his quest for
Revenge just yet this is another huge
step in his personal healing process
throughout its more recent Seasons Rick
and Morty has dealt with the tension
between classic Rick and Morty
Adventures versus the show's Canon and
persistent narrative the episodic sci-fi
hijinks that make the show fun to watch
versus the plot and character arcs that
truly Elevate the show to another level
but I think what the season 6 premiere
does is make clear that both of these
things don't have to be in Conflict both
are meaningful and important this
episode and I suspect this season are
gonna be about how Rick copes with his
grief using the classic styled
Adventures but now embracing his newly
found and chosen family the creators of
the series are combining these two parts
of the show and in doing it they
suddenly hit on something important
sometimes you don't realize when you're
healing sometimes it's only after the
fact that you look back and see how much
you've grown and if you ask me making
this season a bunch of episodic sci-fi
Adventures while secretly also being
Rick's Healing Art is how you move
forward is it a prediction is it wishful
thinking Well for now we're just gonna
call it a theory a film Theory and hey
if you enjoyed this analysis of what
Rick and Morty has to say about coping
with grief and the loss of loved ones
and you're going to want to subscribe
because as interesting episodes like
this pop up we'll be covering all their
deeper things as soon as we can after
the episode airs because you know you
gotta be smart if you're gonna truly
appreciate Rick and Morty and hey in
case you missed it check out this video
you see on screen right now where we
talked about what the show has to say
about the depressing reality of living
in modern society nothing says uplifting
feel-good content online like a deep
philosophical discussion on why
Happiness Is A Lie enjoy that one my
friends and as always I'll see you next
week